entre corentin le furet aurélie trouvé
on continue de s'intéresser à la
campagne des élections régionales notre
série se poursuit elle se poursuit ce
soir en ile de france d'après les
enquêtes d'opinion pas de doute c'est
valérie pécresse qui tient la corde le
rn et 2e et ce qui va être intéressant
cette voie aussi ce qui se passe à
gauche les enjeux et la campagne sur le
terrain c'est ce soir avec jérôme rabier
et norbert evangelista et là la sérénité
d'une présidente de région sortante
porté par des sondages qui la donnent
largement favorite
en déplacement dans un vaccinodromes du
val d'oise valérie pécresse veut
incarner la candidate qui protège en
période de covit bien sûr mais pas
seulement
ces thèmes de la protection je crois est
un thème très important les les
franciliens ont découvert que la région
était là pour les protéger et qu'elle
était extrêmement active et nous
continuerons évidemment dans le second
mandat
crédité de plus de 30 % dans les
sondages valérie pécresse a désigné son
principal adversaire
la gauche à qui elle avait repris la
région en 2015 il ya clairement deux
choix de société entre une gauche
radicale qui a perdu sa boussole
républicaine et qui est décroissante et
droite qui a fait le choix à la région
de sourire très largement de rassembler
très largement
et surtout de faire de la sécurité de
l'écologie des résultats et de la des
valeurs de la république et de la
justice son cap
si la candidate soutenue par les
républicains élus dei cible la gauche
c'est qu'elle sait que le principal
adversaire est là pour elle même si pour
l'instant ses différentes composantes
partent en ordre très dispersé et sont
au coude à coude aux environs de 10%
dans les sondages
clémentine autain rêver d'union elle
part finalement seul à la tête d'une
liste france insoumise partis
communistes les écologistes on te
souhaiter se compter au premier tour
ce jour-là à argenteuil dans le val
d'oise julien bayou vient dénoncer un
projet d'urbanisme mêlant commerces
habitations et multiplexes et là je vois
pas l'intérêt de qui en fait les
recettes de la mairie la région elle a
une vraie compétence en matière
d'aménagement du territoire
nous on veut acté le zéro artificielle
de son est la protection des ce qu'on
appelle les trams les trames vertes et
train bleu les continuités justement
pour protéger la biodiversité protéger
les arbres les îlots de fraîcheur pour
cette campagne l'ancien militant pour le
droit au logement a troqué son look
décontracté pour le costume chemise
question de crédibilité pour celui qui
se rêve en tête de la gauche au premier
tour pour rassembler ensuite ses
l'écologique et dans la centralité du
débat aujourd'hui
lutter contre les les la canicule
améliorer la cantine bio pour nos
enfants
faire le lien entre emploi santé
alimentation c'est ça le projet
écologiste et c'est ça qui peut
rassembler à ses côtés sur les rangs de
la gauche mais néanmoins concurrentes
audrey pulvar rêve elle aussi de mener
la liste d'union de la gauche second
tour et pour elle c'est normal de partir
séparées au premier cas on n'est pas
désunis on a trois offres politiques de
gauche écologiste a acquis sont pas tout
à fait les mêmes et donc nous défendons
nos idées nous défendrons nos programmes
ce jour-là à pontault combault la
candidate pense en commun est venu
parler emploi et promet qu une banque
publique d'investissement régional
financera les projets en ce sens je veux
absolument faire de l'économie sociale
et solidaire et l'économie circulaire un
secteur majeur de l'économie
francilienne le ss c'est le secteur qui
a le mieux résisté à la crise cosy dans
l'île de france et c'est par hasard
c'est un secteur qui est basée sur
l'humain sur le proche sur le lien
social sur le faire ensemble
diviser la gauche devrait être devancé
au premier tour par la liste
lrm menée par laurent saint martin aux
environs de 15 % si l'on se fie aux
derniers sondages
peu connu du grand public il rêve d'être
la surprise de ce scrutin
je préfère être reconnus connu parce que
la politique je crois mérite des
personnes qui ont envie de s'engager à
fond qui a envie de s'engager pour les
six prochaines années qui n'ont pas
d'autres ambitions nationales que
l'avenir de la région ile de france et
donc pour toutes ces raisons je ne crois
pas que la notoriété sont un problème et
vous savez les franciliens vont voter
d'abord pour des idées pour des
personnes qui sont sincères et qui ont
envie de s'engager à leurs côtés pour
les six prochaines années et donc moi
c'est ce combat là que je porte d'abord
deuxième dans les sondages le
rassemblement national emmené par jordan
bardella a peu d'espoir de venir
concurrencer valérie pécresse
quelques interviews dans les médias
nationaux et un minimum de meetings pour
celui qui rêve d'un sursaut de la
participation pour l'emporter
nous gagnerons si et seulement si nous
réussissons à vaincre un ennemi
redoutable l'abstention alors
mobilisation générale
il n'appartient qu'à vous dans ces huit
jours qui nous séparent du premier tour
de vous mobiliser
face à leur fébrilité face à leur
hystérie face à leurs manies d'insulter
tout le monde sans arrêt opposons le
calme des vieilles troupes et de ceux
qui savent que la victoire est au bout
du tunnel
crédité d'un score inférieur à 20% il
aura du mal à progresser au second tour
un second tour qui pourrait voir quatre
listes s'affrontent et en cas d'union de
la gauche avec valérie pécresse en
grande favorite
et comme tous les soirs je vous laisse
découvrir toutes les listes qui se
présentent en ile de france ce sont les
règles d'équité en vigueur durant cette
période électorale vous le savez
maintenant vous nous suivez tous les
jours ici donc les noms des onze têtes
de listes régionales élections qui
auront lieu les 20 et 27 juin prochain
ce dimanche donc avec nous pour le match
des idées corentin le furent bonsoir et
conseiller national du parti ait l'air
conseiller municipal à eaubonne dans le
val d'oise
aurélie trouvé bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes maître de
conférences en économie à agroparistech
et vous êtes porte parole et membre du
bureau d'attac à chaque région ces
problématiques en le voit un petit peu
tous les jours dans nos reportages sur
public sénat en ile de france ça semble
donc bien partie très bien parti même
pour valérie pécresse corentin le furent
que voyez vous dans ces chiffres
positifs par exemple pour la présidente
sortante
je pense que valérie pécresse un bilan
qui est relativement solide en termes je
pense d'investissement soutient par
exemple aux collectivités territoriales
aux territoires en tant qu'élu au cours
du mandat local précédent j'ai pu le
constater des aides attribuées sans
sectarisme
c'est à dire à l'ensemble des
territoires qui en ont besoin pas
forcément avec une sensibilité politique
sur tel ou tel territoire
un fonctionnement qui a été aussi
optimisé je pense des crédits européens
n'étaient pas extrêmement utilisé avant
et qui représentent des mannes
financières importantes de marge de
manoeuvre et d'effets de levier pour les
collectivités et puis un certain
pragmatisme je pense en modernisation
des transports ou du ou du réseau
avec aussi une certaine sanctuarisation
je pense aux autonomes navigo par
exemple depuis quelques années même si à
quelques augmentations au début mais ya
pas non plus d'argent magic avait un
équilibre financier à trouver donc je
pense qu'il ya un bilan relativement
concret qui a mis fin à on va dire un
long héritage de mandature divers gauche
qui n'apportait pas vraiment
satisfaction qui était en bout de
souffle et où on voit d'ailleurs que la
satisfaction dépasse le clivage habituel
droite gauche donc ce qui pour moi
explique ses scores relativement
confortable et particulièrement aussi
l'effet de la fragmentation des forces
de gauche fait aussi que naturellement
lui donner un souffle aux
complémentaires et un pour ne pas dire
pour ne pas dire un quasi boulevard
aurélie trouvé c'est vrai aussi que et
alors il ya le bilan que peut-être
qu'ils pourraient être saluée par les
électeurs de valérie pécresse mais
effectivement il ya cette bouche qui n'a
pas réussi à s'unir quoi alors oui donc
première chose quand même faut que je le
souligne parce que je suis porte parole
d'une association qui est autonome
vis-à-vis cercle où on soutient aucun
candidat même si évidemment je vais le
dire on partage un certain nombre
d'idées globalement de la gauche sociale
et politique
je pense quand même que sur les dix ans
les équilibres actuels enfin les
sondages faut faire attention parce que
valérie pécresse autour des 30% je crois
bon voilà mais quand on additionne en
fait les trois candidats de gauche et de
l'écologie qu'est ont quand même des
gros points comme programme mais en fait
on arrive à 30%
donc vous comprenez pas garé s'unissent
pas donc bas surtout c'est par rapport
au fait que valérie précresse serait
forcément gagnante je pense qu'il faut
être un peu plus prudent sur la
dynamique qui peut y avoir
voilà d'un rassemblement en tout cas de
la gauche et de l'écologie au second
tour qui peut aussi amener des électeurs
à dire bon ben la voilà il ya les moyens
d'en porter d'emporter la région la
deuxième chose c'est que évidemment moi
je suis responsable d'une association
attac est très attentif aux questions
écologiques et sociales à question de la
solidarité on est en ile de france où il
ya des très grandes inégalités sociales
bon moi j'habite le 93 à montreuil vous
imaginez bien que je vis dans un
territoire qu'est nettement plus
défavorisés que
voilà dans les hauts-de-seine où que
sagement et donc il ya cette
problématique là j'ai aussi dans une
commune qui a plus de 30 % de logements
sociaux
or je crois que c'est important de
pointe est ce la sphère qu'il ya des
communes qui sont hors la loi qui ne
respectent pas les minimum de logements
sociaux et d'autres qui sont au delà
mais que justement le conseil régional
ne soutient pas suffisamment donc je
crois que là il ya un vrai boulevard
pour la gauche et l'écologie
je dirai aussi que la question de la
gratuité à terme des transports et des
cantines pour en tout cas les plus
démunis notamment dans les lycées
puisque le conseil régional a la
compétence je crois que c'est
extrêmement important
à une époque on a vu où il ya des jeunes
qui souffrent énormément de la crise
sanitaire de la crise sociale la même
façon qu augmenter l'aide alimentaire me
semblerait de la part du conseil
régional et c'est ce que porte la gauche
et l'écologie
une très bonne chose voilà en tout cas
des questions de solidarité au sein de
l'ile-de-france qui me semblent voilà
extrêmement important aujourd'hui
comment tu allais faire bon jeu
je ne pourrais pas rebondir sur
l'ensemble des sites est mieux qu'un
thème en particulier qui qui sur lequel
je voudrais réagir qu'est la question
effectivement du logement social ou pour
moi on est parti depuis quelques années
d'une intention donc sur la
structuration de la loi sru qui a été
effectivement la valorisation
ce qu'on pourrait appeler du bien vivre
ensemble aussi la mixité sociale est
tout à fait louable avec de l'autre côté
un certaine extrême qui est ce critère
de 25% moi je les jeux les expérimentés
aussi en tant qu'élu imposé de manière
monolithique et très rigide sur des
territoires qui ont des grandes
diversités sans qu'il y ait derrière un
manque délibérée de volonté politique
voire une reculade parce qu'on a on a
toujours un peu tendance à dire on a
certains maires qui veulent pas ou qui
veulent faire des ghettos de riches et
aux autres
il ya des dérives mais le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a cet aspect
monolithique qui fait que même pour des
villes qui joue le jeu c'est à dire
qu'ils s'inscrivent dans un schéma
progressif avec un objectif de 25
eh bien parfois il suffit même de ne pas
être à 25 % à l'instant t
alors que vous ne pouvez pas
matériellement lettres pourtier et
derrière des pénalités des amendes sru
donc le fait de vouloir favoriser la
mixité sociale
je pense qu'il ya personne qui sera
contre mais il ya aujourd'hui au niveau
de cette loi un caractère obsolète parce
qu'elle ne tient pas compte de l'extrême
diversité des territoires
et ce n'est pas qu'une question de
mauvaise foi de certains élus toutes
dernières questions rapides sur ce
chapitre des régionales le fait que le
gouvernement soit particulièrement
mobilisés dans cette campagne électorale
on a vu que jean castex c'était des
confiné lui-même aujourd'hui en allant
dans le dans le centre val de loire pour
soutenir un marc fesneau
on sait aussi que emmanuel macron
poursuit son tour de france et qu'il ira
demain dans les hauts de france alors
évidemment ça tombe dans un territoire
qui est ce lui a priori de xavier
bertrand donc ça pourrait lui faire
concurrence comment vous voyez cela vous
vous trouvez que le gouvernement
nationalise le scrutin en faisant cela
qu'il va trop loin qu'il ne devrait pas
être aussi mobilisée au contraire après
tout il a besoin d'ancrage local
aurélie trouvé en tout cas ce que je
trouve important c'est que ce soit une
pour le coup une question politique
semble ce soit une question politique a
tendance à dire que les conseils
régionaux ont quand même aujourd'hui des
compétences très importantes il ya une
décentralisation en france notamment et
je le dis parce que souvent et quand
j'entends valérie pécresse quand on met
en avant par les questions de sécurité
avant de mettre en avant les questions
de d'éducation de formation de culture
de développement économiques qui sont
les vraies compétences du conseil
régional
ses compétences à aujourd'hui à l'heure
d'une crise économique et sociale la
question aussi de la fonction
d'aménagement du territoire tout ça est
extrêmement important et donc je trouve
que c'est bien en tout cas d'en faire
une question politique y compris à
l'échelle nationale ce qui concerne les
élections régionales effectivement vu la
taille des nouvelles régions et des
réformes
on a forcément de dimension nationale
ensuite c'est ce qui se passe au niveau
de la république en marche c'est que
c'est un parti qui a extrêmement peu
dans le crash territoriale énormément de
candidats sont de parfaits inconnus
aujourd'hui la république en marche
c'est emmanuel macron et quelques poids
lourds quelques grosses figures bon ce
qui explique que forcément on voit dans
les différentes régions on envoie des
ministres partir le vendredi soir une
opération campagne revenir le dimanche
mais aussi de bonne guerre c'est de
bonne guerre mais ça passe ça marche pas
vraiment quand on regarde les sondages
c'est ça c'est ce qu'ils verront
forcément ils n'ont pas d'autre choix
que de tenter une opération
sauve-qui-peut de poids lourd puisque la
plupart des candidats sont absolument
pas identifié on le voit en ile de
france
le candidat laurent sarmates saint
martin dans les débats est pas moins
pertinent qu'un autre mais il s'ouvre
d'un d'un déficit de notoriété tels
qu'une fois de plus ça contribue aussi
au boulevard de valérie pécresse alors
au chapitre notre chapitre chapitre
qu'ovide les annonces sanitaire du jour
elles sont plutôt positives alors on en
profite un peu elles sont venus un peu
par surprise il faut le dire à la mi
journée
après le conseil des ministres annonce
de jean castex en personne écoute et le
port du max année stayers ne sera donc
plus obligatoire sauf dans certaines
circonstances quand on se regroupe
quand on se trouve dans un lieu bondé
une files d'attentes sur un marché ou
encore dans les tribunes d'un stade
les arrêtés préfectoraux qui régissent
le port du masque en extérieur seront
donc modifié dès demain pour traduire
cette nouvelle règle de bon sens on
regarde l'évolution de la situation
épidémique
deuxième évolution le couvre-feu à 23
heures qui devait vous le savez
s'appliquer jusqu'au 30 juin cessera de
s'appliquer à compter de ce dimanche
soit dix jours avant la date prévue
aurélie trouvé une petite musique est en
train de circuler y compris d'ailleurs
ici au sénat sur sept ce cadeau surprise
à trois jours d'un scrutin à quelques
jours d'un scrutin alors je sais pas si
ça vous semble sérieux ou pas mais est
ce qu'on pourrait imaginer qu
effectivement en tout cas je trouve que
la fin du couvre-feu de mon point de vue
elaph est une bonne chose que ça la fin
d'une aberration ça fait partie toutes
ces décisions qui ont été prises de
manière je dirais en tout cas non
expliqué discrétionnaire parfois pas
suffisamment dans un cadre démocratique
notamment à l'assemblée nationale la
france est un des seuls pays à l'avoir
appliqué bon moi j'ai évidemment je fais
partie des organisations très critique
sur la façon dont a été géré cette crise
sanitaire du stop and go inefficace on
aurait pu avoir un d'un confinement
beaucoup plus efficace et ensuite faire
repartir les choses voilà et il ya eu
tout un tas de décisions comme ça qu'on
a du mal à comprendre donc au moins pour
ça c'est une bonne chose mais je dois
dire quand même quand même je dois
rappeler que cette crise sanitaire n'est
pas terminée et c'est une prise mondiale
il ya encore des variants qui circulent
donc prudents et puis surtout cela va
devenir et c'est déjà une question de
solidarité internationale faut pas
oublier qu'il ya énormément de pays dans
le monde qui sont dans une extrême
grande difficulté et ça pose la caisse
une autre question qu'on va peut-être
pas développés estime etc et la question
des brevets de la solidarité
internationale et de la façon de rendre
dans le domaine public les brevets sur
les vaccins pour que ces vaccins puisse
être accessible à l'ensemble des pays du
monde on est content qu'en france on
puisse se faire vacciner mais il faut
savoir que dans beaucoup de pays du
monde est pour beaucoup de populations
ça n'est pas aujourd'hui possible et ça
peut potentiellement nous revenir de
toute façon la figure corentin les
annonces du premier ministre on a
entendu depuis dix mois à peu près
tellement de mesure absurde quand de
temps en temps on a des mesures de bon
sens il faut les saluer je pense que
jean castex était heureux de lui même
pour une fois de sérieux d'annoncer une
bonne nouvelle
et parce qu'ils n'iront lui a quand même
fait peser beaucoup de choses cet homme
là sur les épaules maintenant bon plus
sérieusement le couvre-feu il est mort
avait depuis la demi finale nadal
djokovic est quand même arrivé dans un
système où il fallait une autorisation
d'une dérogation pour une demi-finale
donc forcément le truc était plutôt
nabeul ça n'avait pas grand sens de
toute façon et pays était en train de
craquer dans le pays une fois que tu as
ton était en train de craquer il ne
change pas grand chose puisque de façon
si vous êtes en terrasse et qu'on vous
dit à 23h de partir beaucoup continuent
en milieu clos la soirée dans personne
n'est dupe quant au port du masque on
rappelle que ce n'est pas le fait que
personne ne portera maintenant le masque
en effet en extérieur mais de supprimer
via les arrêtés préfectoraux
l'obligation par défaut si vous êtes sur
un marché une halle avec plein de monde
autour de vous c'est du bon sens de
remettre le masque si vous rentrez seul
et vous êtes tout seul dans la rue vous
allez bel air un peu bête pour être poli
à tout seul avec votre nas donc c'est
certainement beaucoup
lorsqu'en plus pour respirer surtout
avec le ce genre de météo
voilà donc c'est du bon sens
effectivement par contre comme le disait
madame c'est pas on passe pas de la
restriction à la folie il faut une fois
de plus que le bon sens soit respectée
et force est de constater quand même
qu'avec l'évolution des chiffres les
français ont quand même majoritairement
respecté ce qu'on leur a demandé
mais il faut pas voilà il faut trouver
un juste milieu donc d'écouter pour une
fois qu'on a un peu de bon sens s'est
réjoui son danse originale et revenons
maintenant sur cette info donnée hier
par la mairie de paris et qui provoque
un certain nombre de réactions
parfois positive parfois négative le
stationnement va devenir payant pour les
deux roues à essence à partir de 2022 ce
sera 3 euros de l'heure pour les
voitures ça passera d'ailleurs à 6 euros
par endroits dans la capitale 6 euros de
l'heure
avant d'en parler avec vous en plateau
on va accueillir dans ce match des idées
david belliard bonsoir vous êtes adjoint
à la mairie de paris en charge de la
transformation de l'espace public et
merci beaucoup d'intervenir dans ce
match des idées vous l'avez entendu
j'imagine cette colère des conducteurs
de deux roues les motards notamment qui
nous parle carrément de raquette vous
vous y attendiez j'imagine aussi
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur dire pour
apaiser cette tension
d'abord il ya pas de raquette ce qu'on
est en train de faire c'est que nous
rétablissons d'une certaine manière une
forme d'injustice puisque jusqu'à
maintenant les automobilistes paient une
contribution à usages de l'espace public
alors que les propriétaires et les
utilisateurs de deux roues motorisés les
motos les les scooters et bien ne n'en
payez pas puisqu'il y avait la gratuité
c'est un régime d'exemption à laquelle
nous mettons fin et nous mettons fin
d'abord parce que c'est encore une fois
une question d'équité entre les
utilisateurs de l'espace public et puis
c'est aussi une question plus large
d'une logique que la plus globale
lorsque vous utilisez à deux roues
motorisés et vous fait beaucoup de bruit
beaucoup de nuisances sonores et c'est
particulièrement vrai aujourd'hui un lot
de laits parisiennes et parisiens sont
habitués avec la crise sanitaire que
nous vivons est bien à une ville qui est
une ville un peu plus apaisé et sont
beaucoup plus sensibles à la question du
bruit
et puis il ya aussi les questions de
pollution de pollution de l'air et il
est normal juste d'une certaine manière
que celles et ceux qui produisent ces
nuisances et bien participent compense
d'une certaine manière avec un un
paiement de l'usaj de l'espace public
pour permettre à la collectivité qui est
pari d'investir dans la transition écolo
de pouvoir avoir des investissements
d'aménagement puisque par exemple nous
avons proposé avec cette réforme bien la
création de 5000 nouvelles places pour
les deux roues motorisés tout ça ce sont
des coûts et il me semble de bonne
gestion et de bonne justice de permettre
de favoriser en tout cas la contribution
de ses usagers à l'effort collectif
mais lire on apprend aussi si je me
trompe un col stationnement va devenir
payant dans les bois de vincennes et les
bois de boulogne 4 euros de l'heure à
partir de l'automne prochain si je ne me
trompe pas que dites-vous là cette fois
aux familles qui aux familles de
banlieue qui viennent de banlieue qui
viennent faire qu'ils venaient faire des
pique-niques c'est fini non sur ce
samedi le samedi où on sera un euro 60
de leurs pour permettre un usage du bois
familiale justement et le dimanche reste
reste gratuit pour être parfaitement
complet là encore dans les bois on a des
problèmes d'encombrement on a des
problèmes d'abus de places qui sont
effectivement déplace aujourd'hui
gratuité qui ne sont pas utilisés par
des gens qui vont au bois et nous avons
aujourd'hui besoin que ce soit à
vincennes ou à boulogne vient de mieux
réguler encore une fois c'est un outil
de régulation et moi je le dis aussi
notre volonté c'est de favoriser
d'inciter à l' usage d'autres mobilité
que celle de la voiture individuelle
utiliser les transports en commun s'est
déjà d'ailleurs le cas massivement
puisque j'entends beaucoup de choses sur
les réseaux sociaux beaucoup de choses
dans les médias mais il faut se rappeler
toujours d'un chiffre 80 % des
déplacements banlieue paris paris
banlieue sont d'abord faites par les
transports en commun et sur les 20% qui
reste bien il y a énormément de trafic
lié aux mobilités dix professionnels et
ses professionnels là je pense notamment
aux commerçants et aux artisans
bénéficie grâce à une carte qui
s'appelle pro mobile est bien de tarifs
extrêmement attractifs ces 50 centimes
de l'heure mais vous êtes d'accord avec
moi david belliard et après évidemment
on en discutera en plateau que les
transports en commun ne soient
accessibles que lorsque vous avez tout
votre motricité que vous n'avez pas de
poussettes que vous n'avez aucun
handicap
ça veut dire que certains endroits de
paris je ne seront plus accessibles à
ces gens là non non parce que nous
travaillons justement sur les questions
d'accessibilité alors un autre
hier je le sais je le concède sur les
transports en commun et là-dessus
j'entendais votre invité tout à leur
parler du bilan de valérie pécresse
belleville handball eric ress c'est le
fait qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons que 4 5
% des stations de métro à paris et et
plus largement que en métropole de grand
paris qui ne sont pas accessibles mais
plus juste sur la question permettez moi
du handicap
nous allons créer mille places
supplémentaires aujourd'hui réservées
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
ces places pmr
nous aurons à peu prés 5800 places à
terme à paris et évidemment ce
stationnement le stationnement il reste
payant et il sera étendu progressivement
cette gratuité sera étendu
progressivement au stationnement en
sous-sol pour justement permettre par
exemple aux personnes en situation de
handicap de pouvoir circuler et pour
voir se déplacer parce que effectivement
la mobilité doit être un droit
accessible à toutes et à tous alors si
vous le permettez on va évidemment
discuter de tout ce que vous avez dit
sur ce plateau et je vous laisserai
réagir si vous le souhaiter évidemment
corentin le fur mais bon sur le sur le
tard qu'ils aillent d'eux-mêmes pécresse
me suis pas représentants de pécresse
les électeurs auront l'occasion de
trancher dans très peu de temps donc on
va passer à la suite sur le sur les
annonces il ya deux choses en fait moi
je fais une différence entre
la réglementation sur les deux roues
motorisés et l'autre aspect qui est
l'augmentation des tarifs visiteurs pour
les voitures à partir du mois d'août sur
le premier aspect effectivement c'est
pas l'élément qui me semble le plus
choquant à la base les deux roues en
plus ont la possibilité de se garer
si je ne m'abuse y compris sur des
places préserver initialement des
voitures dont il ya un principe d'équité
pourquoi des automobilistes perret et
palais de rohan soit c'est pas le
principe qui me semble plus j'en aurais
pu faire ça dans le sens inverse ne peut
faire payer personne
oui mais savez je pense que peut-être
que la mairie de paris a besoin d'argent
oui peut-être mais simple non la
question derrière c'est surtout la
question justement de l'augmentation des
tarifs dits visiteurs côté voitures
inciter aux mobilités douces moi je suis
le premier je prends les transports en
commun n'ont qu'à pas de souci là-dessus
le seul problème c'est qu'on sait très
bien qu'avec cette logique est toujours
un peu la même d'écologie très punitive
très taxe hâtive ont fait quelque part
une certaine discrimination puisque les
6 euros par heure pour les quartiers les
plus centraux de paris
évidemment que tout le monde ne veut pas
se les payer et qu'il ya certaines
personnes et pas que des oeufs sur des
aspects professionnels qui ne l'ont pas
d'autre possibilité d'utiliser leur
voiture
c'est la même logique les restrictions à
l'intérieur du périmètre de l'a86 on
décrète qu'en fait on va supprimer les
problèmes où on va faire de nouvelles
incitations comportementale juste avec
quelque part détails puisque c'est
assumé avec ce tarif le stationnement en
parking souterrain va devenir quasiment
plus intéressant financièrement que en
surface
donc le problème c'est que on crée une
taxe non résoudra de toute façon pas le
problème puisque si on ne va pas
derrière avec un minimum d'incitation
pour les foyers les plus modestes ça
devrais je dire et sensibiliser la
mairie de paris actuellement par les
gens ne le verront que côté taxes et ils
continueront ils prendront le risque ils
fraudent rond ayant qu il est bien là où
ils ne viendront absolument plus et on
al'impression vraiment que paris se
referme de plus en plus surtout les
banlieusards qui sont de plus en plus ce
expulsé par danny trineer d'une autre
mais justement j'ai envie de
enfin d'abord je pense que je partage
tout à fait ce que dit david lire sur la
nécessité aujourd'hui dans paris de
diminuer absolument la pollution sonore
évidemment la pollution de l'air qui est
un énorme problème de santé publique
invisible mais qui est un énorme
problème qui écoute des qui coûte
d'etion sait combien à la sécurité
sociale qui met aussi qui voilà qui tue
la pollution de l'air aujourd'hui tu me
voilà donc c'est un énorme problème à
prendre en charge et oui il faut faire
diminuer j'espère qu'on est d'accord là
dessus il faut faire il faut absolument
diminuer le trafic automobile dans paris
et plus largement dans l'île de placer
sur l'objectif alors une fois qu'on a
dit ça effectivement ça veut dire que
pour pas avoir une écologie punitive qui
lie l alternative et notamment pour les
plus modestes
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut mettre le
paquet sur les transports en commun
notamment banlieue banlieue on en
parlait tout à l'heure dans un mois je
suis à montrer si je veux aller à saint
denis qui n'est quand même pas loin à 20
minutes en voiture en transport en
commun ils font montre une heure une
heure et demie bon blain est pas rare en
général c'est blindé alors voilà et puis
avec une poussette pour l'avoir fait il
n'y a pas si longtemps que ça c'est
l'enfer voilà donc ça veut dire
qu'effectivement qu'il faut mettre le
paquet est juste on en revient à notre
premier sujet bas c'est exactement ce
que là dessus que la gauche et
l'écologie
voilà veulent veulent agir au niveau
régional
exactement parce que là pour le coup on
est sur les compétences du conseil
régional et de ce point de vue là il me
semble pas que dans les dernières années
et sous valérie pécresse ait eu un
changement absolument édifiant excusez
moi là-dessus mais je ne crois pas et je
crois à mon avis que les la question
c'est est-ce que ces mesures arrivent
trop tôt alors avant qu'on ait mis au
point des transports va là-bas ce qu'il
faut faire il faut faire les deux en
même temps donc effectivement mais il
faut il faut quand même prendre les deux
bouts à mon avis et la deuxième chose
et tant mieux si les les recettes de 2,7
voilà deux les recettes les nouvelles
recettes publiques permettent ça il faut
aussi notamment permettre l'accès par
exemple aux vélos et aux vélos
électriques - utilisant aussi le vélo
dans paris je peux vous dire qu'ils
manquent encore de la sécurité pour les
vélos mais il manque aussi la halle
s'est par exemple au vélo et oui tout à
fait et il manque aussi l'accès aux
vélos électriques par exemple un aidons
il faut des mesures sur les familles les
plus modestes il faut tout un tas
d'aménagement pour pouvoir garer ses
vélos puis voilà donc il ya
effectivement beaucoup à faire sur les
alternatives mais pour moi il faut
prendre les deux bouts et je pense que
du coup ça ça va dans le bon sens à
condition effectivement qu'on est aussi
à la tête du conseil régional et bien
des dirigeants qui qui justement mettre
le paquet là dessus et à condition de ne
pas braquer la population david belliard
où vous ne prenez pas le risque que ce
soit contre productif et que finalement
au lieu d'emmener avec vous un certain
nombre de personnes voulaient braquer
mais d'abord aujourd'hui ce que je suis
en train de vous présenter nous l'avions
proposé pendant la campagne des
municipales j'étais tête de liste
écologiste anne hidalgo était tête de
liste
paris en commun nous avons fusionné ça
fait partie de notre projet le projet
municipal en a on fait ce que nous avons
dit nous disons ce que nous avons fait
ce que nous disent nous avons dit ce que
nous allons faire et nous faisons
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons dit dont
les choses sont en grande transparence
et les gens ont voté pour nous là aussi
en toute transparence ce que nous
faisons c'est effectivement une nous
sommes dans une logique et une logique
de transformation et je partage
complètement ce qui vient d'être dit
vient d'être dit on a des enjeux qui
sont des enjeux majeurs en termes de
dérèglement climatique en termes de
pollution de l'air de santé de santé
publique c'est la raison d'ailleurs pour
laquelle nous ne souhaitons pas la
gratuité parce que ce n'est pas qu'une
question financière quand vous utilisez
votre voiture quand vous utilisez un
deux-roues cadres ou thermique parce que
je rappelle que l'électrique restera
gratuit lorsque vous utilisez ce type
d'engin et bien il a ce qu'on appelle en
économie des externalités négatives ces
externalités négatives
ce sont des coups que nous subissons
tout et tous ces les coudes pour notre
santé pour le coût pour notre qualité de
vie
les coûts aussi pour la collectivité
bien ses couilles peu ils doivent être
en partie du moins compensée par les
usagers de ces de ses véhicules et je
trouve que aujourd'hui c'est une logique
et une logique de à la fois de bonne
gestion et et équité et encore une fois
enfin vous avez parfaitement raison
ça ne peut pas être l'alpha et l'oméga
ces questions de grille tarifaire d'une
politique de transformation
il faut investir dans les transports en
commun et ça c'est la région qui doit
aujourd'hui le
r c'est sa responsabilité c'est
d'ailleurs l'un des enjeux majeurs du
choix qu'il y aura à faire dimanche
prochain et puis il faut aussi investir
dans les alternatives des alternatives
nous le faisons je suis parfaitement
d'accord nous avons fait un grand pas
sur la question ou en tout cas un grand
coup de peut être sur la question
du vélo à paris il nous faut encore
progresser je suis moi-même utilisateurs
de vélo et je vois à quel point les
continuité cyclable ne sont pas encore
optimales parfois c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
et il nous faut investir et ça ce sont
des investissements de plusieurs
dizaines voire de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros et faut tout faire d'un
coup transports en commun alternative
est aussi incitation au des incitations
financières à l'usagé de la voiture
individuelle et on s'arrêtera là désolé
le chrono à tant d'autres sont vite je
voudrais pas l'occasion de répondre à ce
qu'il vient de dire en tout cas merci
infiniment à tous d'avoir participé à ce
match des idées fin de cette émission
demain à ma place ce sera alexandre
poussard à 22h30 moi je vous retrouve
dimanche dès 22 heures aux côtés de
brigitte boucher pour une édition
spéciale de deux heures autour du
premier tour des élections régionales et
départementales sur les chaînes
parlementaires
demain matin bonjour chez vous et c'est
pas ce sera steve jourdain qui recevra
frédéric péchenard tête de liste lr à
paris pour les régionales en île de
france je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur le mixeur